bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tout je me
présente je suis andré joseph bouglione
je suis membre d'une famille de sir que
certains d'entre vous connaissent
peut-être en 1991 suite à une scission
familiale j'ai quitté la famille et
créer mon propre établissement mon
propre cirque que j'ai appelé à l'époque
le sir joseph bouglione en hommage à mon
grand père joseph qui était considéré
dans le monde entier à l'époque comme un
patriarche du cirque en 1993 donc deux
ans plus tard j'ai rencontré la femme de
ma vie sandrine nous nous sommes mariés
nous avons eu ensemble quatre enfants
dont les deux plus grands aujourd'hui
sont des artistes de cirque et le plus
vieux même fait grimper en déjà deux
fois ils sont donc aujourd'hui acrobates
jongleurs ou magiciens tous les deux et
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir pu leur
transmettre notre savoir-faire notre
notre passion quelque part nous
dirigions notre cirque notre entreprise
comme une famille il faut savoir que
sandrine avait passé un certain nombre
d'années en amérique dans un très grand
cirque américain et avait par la touche
et un certain nombre de disciplines elle
était à la fois écuyère voltigeuse
clooney s'est également madame loyal
magicienne et surtout dresseuse
d'animaux sauvages ou domestiques donc
du cheval à l'éléphant passant par les
tigres lions n'importe quelle sorte
d'animal n'importe quelle espèce elle
était capable d'obtenir des choses de
travailler avec et donc ensemble nous
dressions nos animaux et nous les
présentions nous même dans nos
spectacles en public tous les animaux
était présentée par sandrine ou moi et
parfois en alternance le même numéro été
prise de lancer un jour par sandrine un
jour par mois notamment les tigres les
tigres avaient un impact très fort sur
le public les enfants les adultes tout
le monde
et il fascinait vraiment le public
voilà merci vous avez compris
il faut que j'essaye maintenant de vous
faire comprendre la relation que nous
avions avec nos animaux c'est une
relation réellement de presque
fusionnelle ça va au delà de l'amour
parce qu'en réalité on les ressent t on
c'était assez curieux à vivre en fait
c'est assez inexplicable avec des mots
cette relation que nous avions avec eux
par exemple pour la pour la figure et
très simplement
quand je passais devant les cages défaut
eh bien ils réagissaient
particulièrement ce qu'il ne faisait
avec personne d'autre
c'est assez curieux quand je sortais de
ma caravane il se redresser il me
regarde et me suivait des yeux me
faisais des des petits bruits des
piscines pour que je les regarde ou que
je leur parle et ça il ne faisait avait
personne d'autre
ou avec sandrine également
et oui et puis nos enfants je crois que
vous avez compris le geste
merci et puis nos enfants ont grandi et
parallèlement bien sûr nos animaux ont
vieilli et nous nous sommes retrouvés
devant le cas de figure 1 où ça a été
assez compliqué pour nous à gérer en
fait
emotionnellement car des animaux qu'on a
connu toute notre vie avec qui on a
partagé autant de choses fortes
quand on les voit malade et qu'on sait
que c'est inéluctable c'est ce que ça
fait partie de la vie on fréquente la
mort aussi et bien un jour par exemple 2
2 nautiques sont tombés malades
madras et dîna c'était nos premiers
tigres les premiers que nous avions eu
hélas il commençait à être assez vieux
et un jour je me rappelle que madras qui
était très affaibli avait en fait un
problème de paralysie des membres
postérieurs
donc nous avons décidé de ne surtout pas
le faire travailler sauf qu'il était en
cage avec les autres congénères les
autres tigres et au moment du spectacle
quand on a lancé la musique juste avant
le numéro des tigres est bien les tigres
ont réagi comme d'habitude se sont levés
et ont commencé à tourner en cage parce
qu'ils savent ils savaient qu'ils
allaient rentrer en cash en piste mais
lui madras alors qu'il était paralysé
des membres inférieurs il s'est levé
aussi comme les autres mais en se
traînant sur les pattes arrières pour
aller vers la cage
ça nous a bouleversés surtout le regard
qui nous a lancé parce qu'ils ne
comprenaient pas ce qui lui arrivait en
fait il avait envie d'aller travailler
et quelque part il nous en voulez de ne
pas le laisser faire alors qu'il n'en
n'était plus capable physiquement
comment continuer effectivement à
exploiter des animaux à les dresser pour
les présenter en spectacle qui plus est
pour de l'argent
l'activité du dressage a beau être
parfaitement légale nous commencions à
nous poser de sérieuses questions quant
à son aspect éthique son aspect moral
la captivité
voilà il faut savoir une chose c'est que
quelqu'un était là la qualité des soins
que nous leur apportions quelle qu'ait
été la grandeur et la sincérité de
l'amour que nous avions pour chacun
d'entre nous n'étions capable in fine et
que de leur donner une captivité avis la
prison à perpétuité
or si on y réfléchit bien quand on
enferme un être humain à perpétuité
c'est la punition pour un crime
et là je commençais à douter
sérieusement de l'activité tout
simplement parce que je ne comprenais
pas quel prix quel crime il avait bien
pu commettre pour que nous leur
infligeons une telle peine
pourquoi les ans ferme ton et ça c'est
très important parce que je me suis posé
cette question un certain temps et en
fait je pense que la raison est très
simple
bien sûr moi je les enfermer par
habitude parce que j'ai été élevé comme
ça ça faisait partie de notre de notre
mode de vie nous sommes nés avec des
animaux sauvages
moi même j'ai pratiquement appris à
marcher en maintenant sur sur le dos
d'un petit lion ou d'un petit hic de
singe voyez mais oui voila quoi qu'il
arrive
moi j'habite là à improviser l'agglo
parker c'est très compliqué merci mais
quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'on fasse même en augmentant au
maximum le bien-être en donnant des
cages magnifique faisant tout ce qu'on
peut pour augmenter le bien-être en fait
en réalité on ne fait que reculer le mal
être dû à la captivité et nous avons
commencé à nous percevoir non plus comme
des artistes mais comme des gardiens de
prison
et il y avait également à côté de ça une
espèce de lassitude du public le public
commencé à bouder nos spectacles
alors au début on a mis ça sur le dos de
plein d'autres choses mais le public
était finalement d'après nous lasser de
la médiocrité voire du charlatanisme ou
du côté arnaqueurs d'un certain nombre
de cirque
quelles que soient leurs dimensions il
faut dire aujourd'hui que dans la
majorité des cirques les spectacles sont
sans souffle sans magie sans sens et
sans charme
la plupart du temps et au mieux on y
voit une troupe de personnes déguisées
en costume de farces et attrapes faire
un petit tour de piste pour les animaux
ça ne vaut guère mieux
ils font de trois tours de piste on ne
sent aucune relation entre l'homme et
l'animal
et ça dépasse la médiocrité c'est au
delà de ça et ça bien sûr les gens ne
veulent plus en voir mais il n'y avait
pas que cette raison et en réalité il y
avait un véritable tabou auquel nous
mêmes nous avions du mal à accéder c'est
à dire que cette pensée là nous gêner
terriblement tout simplement par
habitude par habitude par l'éducation
par la culture finalement que nous avait
légué nos anciens et ce problème il est
y venait tout simplement de la
condamnation du public de l'exploitation
animale tout simplement est
effectivement de plus en plus de
personnes dans le public
condamné le fait de présenter pour de
l'argent ou pas même mais de présenter
en public des animaux sauvages par
ailleurs en grand danger d'extinction
parce qu'il faut savoir aussi que nous
allions un jour nous retrouver ce qui va
arriver malheureusement bientôt c'est
triste mais c'est comme ça dans la
situation d'avoir dans nos cages des
animaux qui aurait disparu à l'état
sauvage et ses animaux il aurait été
dans nos pages uniquement pour faire du
spectacle pour divertir les enfants
d'ailleurs il m'est arrivé à vendargues
décidé d'arrêter l'exploitation animale
que des parents viennent me voir après
leur spectacle après le spectacle avec
leurs enfants à la main pour me
communiquer pour me témoigner de leurs
expériences souvent me dire que le
spectacle était super qu'on avait des
super artiste une ambiance formidable et
qu'on n'avait pas besoin en fait des
animaux que eux ça les gênait finalement
il s'en était rendu compte en direct
tout d'un coup devant leurs enfants
il se mettait dans la position de
diffuser un message à leurs enfants un
message négatif
le message qui dirait que l'homme est
supérieure à la nature qu'il peut se
servir impunément et exploiter tout et
n'importe quoi même les animaux les plus
nobles
malgré leur danger d'extinction alors là
bien sûr c'est un c'est un élément qui a
pesé très lourd dans notre décision
l'opinion des parents et oui est
également est également un jour nous
avons eu très peu de manifestations au
cours de notre carrière en 25 ans depuis
1991 jusqu'à 1900 à 2000 je ne sais plus
14 13 14 on a eu deux manifestations
devant notre s'ils acceptent presque
rien une tous les 15 ans en moyenne
bon bref et est donc la dernière que
nous avons eue elle devait être en 2010
ou 2011 à chatou et là j'ai vu à mon dea
des participants que tenir une pancarte
sur laquelle était noté ce slogan oui au
cirque sans animaux en finalement les
gens que j'avais catalogué parmi nos
ennemis les plus irréductibles les plus
redoutables
ceux qui voulaient notre mort en réalité
ne voulait pas notre mort il voulait
simplement un autre forme de cirque une
forme de ce cirque qui tiennent compte
de l'animal ou carrément qu'ils arrêtent
de l'exploiter encore mieux parce que
comme je le dit tout à l'heure on peut
pas augmenter le bien-être on peut faire
que reculer le mal être
si on examine bien en détail l'histoire
du cirque depuis les années 70 on
constate qu'il n'y a eu absolument
aucune sorte d'évolution
mise à part des progrès techniques donc
parfaitement cosmétiques
c'est plus joli ça a l'air plus propre
c'est plus grand c'est plus facile à
monter mais en termes de modèles
économiques et en terme de chartes
éthiques
si on peut l'appeler comme ça là aucune
évolution
absolument rien n'a changé dans ces 2
modèles par rapport au cirque et donc
nous nous sommes rendus compte qu'en
fait il fallait que nous trouvions une
solution pour renouveler notre art
renouveler notre cirque pour nous bien
entendu mais aussi pour nos enfants et
au sens le plus large possible pour les
générations futures les enfants au sens
large les nouvelles générations l'avenir
et si on faisait un cirque sans animaux
alors au départ la première fois je me
suis posé cette question
ça a été d'une violence terrible non
bien entendu je pouvais pas dire oui
c'était non obligatoirement
catégoriquement nous c'était toute ma
vie toute ma culture toute mon histoire
celle de ma famille de mes ancêtres
c'était absolument inenvisageable toute
ma vie jusque là on m'avait inculqué que
renoncer à l'exploitation animale
c'était une tradition une trahison par
dont la trahison de la trace de la
tradition justement la tradition la
trahison des anciens jeux de mots
compliqués
merci pour votre compréhension
[Musique]
et les anciens justement j'avais bien
l'impression de les entendre me criait
d'outre-tombe le cirque sans animaux
n'est pas du cirque
eh oui non mais ils ont compris
non mais n'entend pas y rit un peu de
respect voilà
[Musique]
et donc ce fut pour moi à cette époque
là le début d'un véritable conflit
intérieur eux n'ont même déconcentre
[Musique]
voilà un jour ce conflit s'est arrêté
quand je me suis posé cette question
très simple pouvait accepter sans
révolte de faire partie de la génération
la mieux informée et la plus
inconsciente et inactifs de toute
l'histoire alors à cette question j'ai
dit non c'est pas possible
quels que soient les problèmes familiaux
la culture l'histoire et c'est à mon
passé et tout ça en fait au sens
beaucoup plus large au sens de
l'humanité finalement on fait tous ici
partie de cette génération là j'ai
rencontré à ce moment là beaucoup de mes
confrères et je leur ai exprimé mon
ressenti tout ce que je ressentais en
fait par rapport au métier par rapport à
plein de choses pas seulement les
animaux
ils m'ont tous absolument sans exception
ce qui a été assez curieux ils m'ont
tous donné raison y compris sur
l'exploitation et la captivité des
animaux mais et alors là ça a été
incroyable comme expérience
tous sans exception également ont
rajouté qu'il ne fallait ni le faire ni
le dire quand même assez curieux or moi
de mon côté je ne pouvais plus vivre
dans ce déni je ne pouvais plus
continuer à faire semblant
je n'y croyais plus ça ne servait plus à
rien à part m'enfoncer dans la
dépression ça ne m'aurait avancée
absolument à rien d'autre il y avait
urgence à agir
mais bien sûr pour agir il faut oser
repenser un peu le monde librement hors
d or des entraves du passé et surtout
il fallait d'abord comment dire
retrouver il fallait surtout m'exprimer
en public il fallait que j'explique ce
ressenti que j'avais à l'époque et bien
à vous à l'opinion publique au sens le
plus large possible
c'est ce que j'ai fini par faire après
encore quelques périodes de doute assez
compliqué et c'est ce que j'ai fini par
faire en mai 2010 cette voie là et là
les réactions
les retombées furent énormes assez
impressionnante
du côté des circassiens les circassiens
ce sont les gens de cirque dans le
métier du côté donc du cirque du métier
du cirque
les réactions sont d'une violence inouïe
mes amis ma famille des confrères des
gens que j'ai toujours connu
tout d'un coup me juge m'insulte de
calomnies menaces même de mort
cette pression là pour me faire arrêter
me faire dire l' inverse de ce que je
venais de dire parce que en réalité il
faut savoir une chose avant d'être le
petit fils de mon grand père
ne suis-je pas aussi voir dave d'abord
un citoyen français parfaitement en
droit d'exercer son métier tel qu'il
l'entend et de s'exprimer d'exprimer ses
opinions aussi librement qu'il le peut
avec un peu de recul je pense avoir
compris aujourd'hui ce qui a
particulièrement gêné les circassiens
mes confrères dans ma démarche
le fait que j'arrête d'exploiter des
animaux les gènes les dérange évidemment
mais ce qui a déclenché une telle levée
de boucliers une telle réaction de
violence c'est surtout pardon c'est
surtout que je tienne le discours qui
est à mon avis à lutter pour le métier
qui est de dire que le cirque
traditionnel va disparaître si ils
continuent à exploiter des animaux ça
c'est en faisant ça j'ai vraiment brisé
un tabou
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui un sondage me
donne raison
il ya quelques mois un sondage est sorti
et son résultat fut que à peu près 60 7%
de la population française condamne et
demande l'interdiction des animaux dans
les cirques assez impressionnant comme
sondage plus des deux tiers de la
population française
le cirque spectacle populaire par
excellence ne peut pas se permettre de
tourner le dos à 67% de la population il
deviendrait élitiste et perdrait son
statut de spectacles populaires
il ne le serait plus du tout d'ailleurs
regarde mon avis il ne l'est déjà plus à
cause de l'exploitation animale et
maintenant avec sandrine nous essayons
de nous avons lancé en fait un projet de
pour renouveler notre art pour
renouveler notre cirque un projet de
cirque bien sûr sans animaux et pour
aller plus loin d'un autre engagement
qui est notre engagement depuis un
certain nombre d'années
un cirque écologique il va s'appeler
l'écho cirque alors pour résumer très
rapidement en quoi ça va à quoi ça va
ressembler eh bien ça sera un cirque
sans camions il y aura pas de camion
tout simplement parce que tout le
matériel va être transportée par
ferroutage par voie maritime ou par
d'autres solutions par des transporteurs
avec lesquels nous sous-traitons
l'électricité également sera fournie par
des panneaux solaires
j'ai déjà trouvé le prototype les
groupes électrogènes au lieu de marcher
au fuel marcheront à l'huile végétale au
colza bien entendu hors de question de
faire ça à l'huile de palme
les costumes du spectacle pour donner
les grandes idées les costumes du
spectacle seront confectionnés sans la
moindre matière animale ni fuir ni plume
ni autre chose on ne sait pas et est
également une partie de notre chiffre
d'affaires sera reversée tous les ans à
l'association objectif 100% humains que
nous venons de créer
et qui servira à financer des projets
dans le monde entier de protection
d'animaux sauvages dans leur habitat
naturel
[Applaudissements]
merci alors et parallèlement à ça bien
sûr nous essayons nous sommes en train
de travailler actuellement à comment
faire revivre la magie du cirque qui a
disparu à mon sens la magie du siècle
mais avec seulement des acrobates des
magiciens des clowns des trapézistes des
musiciens des brefs 100% humains
ça sera un petit peu le sous titre de
notre cirque
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y aura absolument
aucun animal
nous n'exploitons plus que des êtres
humains
alors à côté de ça vous savez j'ai une
passion pour le cirque bien entendu
puisque c'est mon métier et j'ai un vif
intérêt également pour deux autres
disciplines qui sont rien qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec le site qui
sont l'histoire et la philosophie et
cette passion m'a fait remarqué quelque
chose d'assez troublant c'est que
finalement chaque génération au sens
très large
vraiment tout le monde chaque génération
exerce une pression sur celle qui lui
succède pour que tout reste en l'état
comme si le modèle légué n'était pas sûr
passable et qu'aucun autre modèle ne
saurait le remplacer en mieux ce
conservatisme n'était pas dommageable
tant que nous connaissions les mêmes
conditions c'est-à-dire le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
nous vivons dans une véritable
révolution de la nature et ses
conditions tellement changé que nous
sommes obligés de chercher des solutions
nous tous ici nous descendons tous
chacun d'entre nous chacun et chacune
d'entre nous descendons d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont relevé au cours de
l'histoire de l'humanité des défis
exceptionnels les défis incroyables pour
nous pour que nous soyons là ici et
maintenant et bien toutes ses traditions
et ses habitudes dont nous héritons nous
avons arrêté deux eh bien c'était des
solutions à leur époque des solutions
aux problèmes de leur temps aux
problèmes de leur monde et aujourd'hui
ces problèmes ont changé radicalement et
notre devoir à nous à chacun d'entre
nous chacun et chacune d'entre nous
aujourd'hui
à mon sens c'est de chercher des
solutions pour faire face à cette à
cette révolution de la nature
eh oui n'essayons plus de marcher dans
les pas de nos glorieux anciens moi
c'est ce que j'ai arrêté de faire parce
que je me suis rendu compte que c'est en
faisant comme ça que je m'enfonçais dans
l'impasse celle où j'étais à l'époque et
c'est en cherchant par moi même des
solutions originales que j'en suis sorti
de cette impasse et que maintenant je
suis devant vous a parlé d'un projet
assez novateur de cirque écologique et
sans animaux notre devoir en fait notre
devoir de citoyen pour les générations
futures c'est tout simplement de
d'essayer de tout faire en sorte pour
leur léguer des solutions pour leur
avenir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
alors je sais que j'ai été passer
largement mots le temps qui m'était
imparti
mais j'aimerais demander à une personne
de venir avec moi sur scène pour vous la
présenter parce que c'est la personne
qui a été la plus importante à mon avis
dans mon parcours c'est évident non là
j'improvise là il n'y a plus de texte
ah ça vous fait rire hein j'aimerais lui
demander de venir me voir sur scène et
puis surtout je voudrais que vous la
présentez basse et mon épouse sandrine
bouglione j'ai parlé d'elle pendant la
conférence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madden
je parle
[Applaudissements]
il a beaucoup de mérite parce qu'il a
aucune mémoire merci mais non mais c'est
quoi c'est pas grave
merci à tous sans voix
[Applaudissements]